across the world countries are bowing to
the seemingly inevitable
and asking the military to help the
global covid emergency
is worse than ever
in the amazon city of manaus soldiers
are having to collect the seriously ill
and evacuate them to other parts of the
country
other parts aren't much better they just
aren't a complete disaster
well not yet this city was absolutely
flawed in the first outbreak
it's never recovered it's through the
floor now
the families of new admissions are
handed huge oxygen canisters
and are told to go out and get them
filled up or their family member
won't get treatment others have to
source them
where they can the scarcity of oxygen
here is critical now
medical volunteers sometimes have to
decide who lives
and who dies you think jesus
this disaster is growing every day the
uk is overwhelmed so is brazil
the usa europe the americas asia we're
all struggling
but in countries without safety nets the
consequences
are horrendous things are so bad here
they're dependent on venezuela
a completely bankrupt country to help
them out
free to burial undertakers ferry the
dead from their homes
to the pauper's graves of the city it's
a non-stop job now
there were already thousands buried here
22 000
new graves are being dug many fear
though
that 22 000 simply won't be enough
stuart ramsey sky news